making sure that everything goes to plan
and also today taking the salute on
horse guards parade is going to be the
prince of wales but also the palace
making it very clear supported by the
duke of cambridge and the princess royal
and so it's all about showcasing the
family it is very secure they all know
what role is expected of them
oh is that a police yeah looking into
the road yeah we seem to have a couple
of people interrupting demonstrators
yeah the parade there they've rushed in
the police will be very worried about
the soldiers in this situation we've got
to remember that it's an interesting
time
in the world and people
who are of course in a democracy
encouraged to come and enjoy this or
express their views at it but we
do know that the security here because
members of the world finally be coming
down shortly there will be concern to
make sure that soldiers are safe
it's a huge job isn't it for the
security services well there are
thousands of people absolutely as we
speak and they want to make sure that
this occasion is seen to be as open as
possible i was on guard when somebody
fired at the queen with a starting
pistol and he's called mr sergeant and
my corporal for alex galloway grabbed
the
shooter and pulled him over
the
barricade and laid into him with his
boots actually i think by the time the
police turned up
he was begging for the police to take
lance corporal galloway off him but you
know soldiers will do whatever they can
to protect the queen but i know that the
police here have principal
responsibility for security and of
course that is an issue which will need
to be managed as carefully as they
always do yeah the police have acted
there quickly to it looks like two
protesters have managed to gain access
to that procession on the map the mao
police quick to act but what you're
seeing around that is the lying out of
the street liners and very shortly we'll
see the first of the guards coming up
but not until all the street line is
right i think this is the next lot who
will put this red line right underneath
the flags the full length of the mule